nike postpones the release of the travis
scott air max one how do you feel about
that
i'm amazed it took this long
like they just announced yes like they
really thought that she was gonna go
away yeah they were like yeah let's just
hold off for a week let's see if people
forget about it in eight days and then
we'll make a decision then yes if you
really gave why don't you just make this
decision right away the nine-year-old
kid had to die for you to be like you
know what
maybe we don't need to release these
fire ass shoes i mean them shits are hot
those are the ones you were showing me
yesterday yeah no it's a different pair
those are more fire
those are sick right yeah they're saying
they're dope undeniably now you can get
them if you wanted to but how china yeah
we go right to china and get them
straight from the source yeah
the insanity that they thought they
could release a running shoe eight days
after
a [ __ ]
stampede is insane what did those people
need yeah yeah
heir to the max
they were suffocating
and they needed air there's no [ __ ]
way now this is gonna be flying off
shelves one hundred percent oh [ __ ]
yeah travis boy you think that he uh
travis is actually gonna lose some money
i mean
yeah can they sue him though i don't
think so it seems like all the legal
[ __ ] he's protected so then he'll just
have to pay lawyer fees forever so he'll
lose money to the lawyers but he's not
gonna have to pay out any of the people
yeah i don't think so and uh damian
lemon i saw him for the first time in
[ __ ] years
i love damian i saw him on stage
yesterday he was saying he'd been
clocking the price of travis scott
sneakers on stockx hoping it would dip
and it just hasn't so i don't think
public support has really waned that's
funny yeah it's really funny yeah damian
is great man yeah everybody go check out
damien miss damon have you seen everyone
at every concert now
like taking care of all the people that
pass out oh yeah all this cat are you
okay is everything fine are the cameras
on me are you okay
look at that girl right there is she
fine
i've seen like 20 of them so far like
yeah every concert
you have to now that's the norm i also i
kind of think it's good for travis that
this is happening because now people are
realizing like oh people pass out of
concerts all the time yeah
adele has one
like all these people have them for
people who wasn't staged for adele the
adult one was no they probably were
choked on some food
but
that's not anymore
i think so
really i think so i'm a fan
you're on your way you're the exception
that proves the rules dude you're on
your way god damn it okay
um so wait so then people are going to
go to these concerts and then they're
we're going to have to hear the artists
fake care and which if you want
attention from your favorite celebrity
pass out of their show yes that's the
movie go to the front and then just
faint just fall down immediately you'll
have an interaction with people yeah
they'll bring you should bring you on
stage give you water
[ __ ] pee in your mouth who knows who
anything could happen maybe that's what
that woman was doing when the guy passed
out he's gonna revive him we gotta get
him on stage it's like we're out of
smelly shells
a cold bucket of water
he's about to see for sure yeah
oh man what in terms of liability by the
way i'll hear a concert oh yeah
look i'm just saying i can go just say a
little cushy okay get in the cushion
actually i want to get drunk
yes i need to get drunk let's do it i
don't know why let's hey let's start it
off yeah yeah i'm sad i'm sad too akash
yeah stop it with your cbd smoking which
also you never told us about the rest of
the movie stuff what happened with the
movie like has there have there been
other interactions you haven't told us
yeah i spoke to eddie finally for the
first time
do you want to talk about the legal [ __ ]
yeah talk about the legal [ __ ] legal
[ __ ]
um
oh you're a chipmunk that's cute
a cute little chipmunk is what he was
that's what dove is remember travis was
also an organizer of the event not just
a performer a performer most likely
wouldn't be held liable they can sue and
all that
explain the legal framework keep
explaining world keep organizer yeah
they only have a certain limit on that
liability insurance
had a lot of trampling and deaths at one
of their concerts and they didn't suffer
from it but
keep explaining it little doughnuts
you should explain all your things my
things want to get drunk huh should we
get through what are we doing tequila um
i i just uh don't care about any of the
topics so what i'm gonna do is get drunk
and i'm gonna make an absolute fool
about myself about myself of myself and
uh what happened with you and eddie yeah
can you tell us more movie stuff because
the last thing we heard was
that
you had the awkward thing with eddie
where he came in the circle jonah hill
roasted you and you haven't really
talked about it since joan is sweet dude
i'm gonna keep it a buck jonas which i
actually think he was roasting because
he knows your sensibility and that
probably made you feel way more
comfortable no like i i
i i i think good intentions with him i
mean
like
i think good execution him making fun of
you i think makes you feel that's your
element
like someone busting your balls is like
it knocks some sense into you i feel
normal oh that's a good point and he was
able to read your state and be like oh
yeah maybe this guy needs to get told
he's an idiot you're like yeah i am an
idiot who's an idiot me
yeah i got a [ __ ] on his face for about
five minutes
and then he'll laugh yeah
we were at the wedding scene and uh
eddie was just kind of like standing
there and uh i was sitting back and then
i don't know how it came up but he asked
me he's like are you a stand-up or
something like that yeah
yeah i said i was some i said i was on
the road or something like that i forget
but not i don't know he was he just
asked me out of the i don't know why no
he goes are you a stand-up and um
i go yeah yeah and i go uh in great part
uh due to you
right wow um
and he goes he goes oh cool and then i
told him the first time i ever listened
to stand up was on a cassette you know
with my father and he uh i mean i was
like a kid i was listening to it on a
cassette it was delirious and he goes uh
that must have been an eye-opening
experience for you like just thinking
about what
the [ __ ] he said the raw [ __ ] he said
nine years old or something like that
and uh he was just really sweet
and it was cool really yeah and i take
back everything i said
[Laughter]
making movies is fun and it was really
just the rejection i felt from uh eddie
murphy my comedic hero that made me uh
not like the movie experience oh see i
thought you were cookie though i thought
you were right about movies
i thought i thought all these
actors like 20 million dollars or wrong
it's still a lot of time dude it's still
a lot of time but i will say this and
jonah said something interesting he goes
like something happens when you complete
70 of a movie
that
where like you see the end and then
everybody gets this um
like celebration euphoria before it's
finished
like it was so weird in this scene like
everybody was kind of like having a good
time we didn't have any lines so maybe
that's why it was also easy but like
people having a good time people in a
good mood like everybody's you know
telling stories busting balls we're
getting drunk you know it was it was
just fun so maybe there's something like
that you're also shooting the finale of
the movie yeah yeah i mean we got to go
back out now yeah this is but this is
like the last day right it was a party
this is gonna be a party in the fun
there's gonna be a real ass party you
should yo
you should try to get eddie on this
podcast i know the wrap party no because
he couldn't even tell eddie in person
like i've got the best stand-up show in
in the world right now and just you want
to be humble a little more you don't
want to be humble yes i'm listening to
delirious on a cassette
bro yo you're dumb you right bro you're
dumb you're right
he's my hero and it was just such a
beautiful thing with [ __ ]
you sound like a nerdy jew [ __ ] dude you
nerdy jew you're my hero mr murphy oh my
god so guys uh having a father president
in your life let me explain uh yeah oh i
know what it's like and it ain't always
great
[Laughter]
oh
god when do we tell akash we have no
lighter in this entire studio
he looks cool holding that button no
it's not going to be like maybe that's
all i needed maybe you're right with the
[ __ ]
just i'm going to stand up
i'll do some of this stuff i didn't
really say that i sounded like [ __ ]
brian regan
[Laughter]
yeah
jermaine jackson
what is that [ __ ] joke he's so in his
way that if he was like where can i see
your stuff and you were like youtube
would be like this [ __ ] stand
up
no that guy's it was [ __ ] cool and
who else was on the set that day though
do you think he even knows where this
movie is going to be like you think he's
ever watched netflix
who eddie i think he just films a [ __ ]
and he's like where's his not going to
the movie all right do whatever y'all do
just pay me yeah yeah that guy just got
a cell phone you think he got netflix
no but he likes him they did dolomite
with him oh no he knows netflix he likes
but he likes that they don't do whatever
he wants to do
he definitely knows netflix
right yes
yes maybe i've described him poorly all
right guys we're going to take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
i got to make sure y'all are making some
money i know you're gambling i know
you're putting your money up why not
also put someone else's money up yeah
you could do that with my bookies money
you use mybookie.ag use our promo code
flagrant they are gonna match your
initial deposit bonus how amazing is
that they match your initial deposit
bonus up to a thousand dollars that's a
three thousand dollars why would you not
gamble with some free money this is a
no-brainer you know you're gonna be
gambling on the games this week akash
who do you think you got this week so i
got the cowboys over the cheese i'll
tell you that [ __ ]
why not akash just gave you his tip
right there he said cowboys over the
cheese if you want to make some money
double up that initial deposit bonus
are they going to have to pay you
anything or no just support the product
just to support the pod that's what it
is
mybookie.hg use the promo code flagrant
initial deposit bonus is
flagrant oh no no it's matched up yeah
okay i got this bro
okay
she's throwing [ __ ] passes like
patrick mahomes over there
one day
now let's get back to this exclusive
patreon clip you can find the whole
episode and many more at patreon.com
flagrant2 join the [ __ ] [ __ ]
army peace what's up with marilyn manson
yeah my man is a wild boy dude he used
to lock his girlfriends in like a small
room like hours
allegedly when he called like the bad
girls room or something like that
and then anytime he said they were
misbehaving and it would be like
apparently the smallest transgressions
what they're saying he would just put
you in the room and lock you in there
for like hours and then one of his
ex-girlfriends would say i'm like
i didn't even fight him at a certain
point because he really enjoyed me
fighting so i just you just have to like
mentally check out and then just go in
the room and then you're just trapped in
this like small space it was a the sound
rook booth the sound booth at his
apartment that he like took all the [ __ ]
out of him you just lock him in there
is this effective or what's the uh
what do you mean
like did it work for him like what's he
i mean not now and i was arrested yeah
but in the time yeah i would i would i
mean it would be big but i would love to
give my wife a soundproof like here you
go just go ahead and you handle what you
gotta handle the actual sound booth but
you would take that i felt soundproofing
in my head that worked yeah i mean where
i just block out words there's no
internal booth that yeah we'll just do
that
that's a decent thing to do as a man
that a woman you love is you built the
soundproofing in here yeah yeah yeah
that's actually nice
he was just too old
like noise cancelling headphones came
out bro the airpods airpod pros changed
the game unreal it really changed the
game like he was putting women in a
little box start arguing just go
exactly boom i'm in my own little box
yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] up that he did that [ __ ]
is that real though
can i victim blame a little bit i know
you're not supposed to victim blame but
i'm going to victim blame a little bit
apparently when you walk in his
apartment is decorated with blood on the
walls um like porno magazine cutouts
everywhere swastikas and then over the
bed spray painted it says aids
if a man got aids spray-painted over his
bed and you wittingly have sex with him
ever you're a wild ass girl though yeah
that's crazy that's like that's what
they say in the same article so if
you're alleging all this to be true
you're accepting all of it is true
i mean [ __ ] come on now
you're just into that house and you walk
out that [ __ ] is amazing
aids
aids is what i saw what are you saying
no i didn't google it i'm just saying
look at the article i sent
god aids like where was it it's right
there in the article i sent brett but
putting putting he's hacky though what
the heck he's hacking i never got his
[ __ ] son he wild hecky i never got his
[ __ ] i was like this guy's a hacker wait
until marilyn manson does one video he's
like yo why you all hating me like
no i just make music i do my own [ __ ]
you're like yo honestly i think we
missed judges maryland
i mean little loser likes him
nah dude i just thought his [ __ ] was
hacked back in the day i never got it yo
i didn't get like okay you got the
makeup on you got like you're showing
your teeth in a weird way in this video
like
kind of singing i guess like i just
didn't get it i was like what is the
point of music sucked you're just weird
what are you speaking to i didn't
understand it and then all these things
like he has all this like a shocking
stuff in his apartment like grow up dude
yeah like you want to do that
no on thursday you want to wake up and
see aids above your [ __ ] bed it's
crazy someone just wake up you know
you're a little [ __ ] exhausted you
had a rough night you don't just wake up
and like be in like a nice bed with some
sheets and walk out there's not blood
all over your [ __ ] walls that'd be
nice wouldn't that be nice dude stop
acting like you don't like nice [ __ ] i'm
tired of these [ __ ] rockstar
dudes i guarantee he's got a house in
like malibu it's absolutely gorgeous he
has like white couches and [ __ ] he
doesn't put the makeup or lipstick on so
he doesn't stain anything this is fake
guaranteed
this whole guaranteed fake i bet he has
a house just to [ __ ] these girls that is
all decorated like that and then there's
another persona is fake yeah yes he
apparently admitted to having the room
in a in a magazine interview in like
2012. of course
it's too much it's trying it's too much
try hard
he he tries hard he yo
i don't think this is natural for
marilyn manson
call me crazy but i don't think this is
who he naturally is
he wasn't born that way i don't think he
was born this way maybe his mom had aids
that's what he saw every morning when he
was in the womb he was like oh hey maybe
maybe he was just trying to remind
himself to help people oh yeah and then
he threw maybe he was a closet he was
like i need to help more than one person
yeah and then the m fell off
how do we know telling the maids to come
yeah hanging out the bag all the blood
everywhere everywhere
[Music]
there's [ __ ] cut outs for magazines all
over the place can you please someone
tidy up yes for once and this is gonna
stick them on it'll take off cobwebs
everywhere that i put there yeah
magazines the guys cutting up magazines
isn't that [ __ ] embarrassing [ __ ]
boomer yeah
explain to these [ __ ] 19 year old
girls what a magazine is yeah you took
these pictures yeah you downloaded this
from a printer what's going on here
dude what a hack bro you cut that [ __ ]
out you can expect that's what he did
no i'm just saying you can exist with
that like troll like weirdo [ __ ] for a
certain amount of time but then
eventually
you gotta just retire
female [ __ ] him in 2015 [ __ ] that's
on you [ __ ]
yo how you [ __ ] this has been yeah
you wearing face paint as 55 bro don't
do that what's the guy's name gene
simmons yeah like he did it right he
wore the face paint did all the kiss
[ __ ] blah blah every once in a while
throw it back on get a reality show but
he got a reality show and he was just a
normal dad with normal [ __ ] kids yeah
nice house
that's way more interesting so much
better if marilyn manson turned to
corner was like yo i'm actually kind of
religious like i've adopted a few kids
like just start raising them bro we'd be
like wow if he just took off the makeup
and he was just like yeah i had a wild
time and it was cool
people cut my hair like i don't wear the
wig makeup anymore because i'm 60 years
old like who gives a [ __ ] yeah and
you're like i banged every rachel wood
she was really annoying so i put her in
a box and then
i wrote aids on my ceiling and now i'm
just a regular dad i was hoping for a
regular day put aids on it like why
would you [ __ ] a guy with aids can
someone let her out she's actually still
in the business
i definitely know where what girl gave
him the idea of like i should just lock
this [ __ ] in a soundproof booth
it had to be that one oh yeah or rose
mcgowan
oh god yeah come on he dates some
annoying ass that's on you fam that is
on you you got horrible tastes bro you
got horrible taste in these annoying ass
girls and that's why you want to put
them in a goddamn box get a cool girl
you want to talk to her all the time
yeah like you're the only one going
through these issues yeah but you need a
wounded ass girl that is willing to date
a you yeah 100. you need a girl dumb
enough to believe you're schtick
yeah you know what i'm saying like you
got to be a dumb girl to see marilyn
manson go he's so brilliant yeah i have
a thing for the babadook i'll date him
come on like how do you not see through
that [ __ ] yeah the beautiful people the
beautiful people yeah
yeah who are you talking about you're
these beautiful people yeah out the
window maybe bro
nah dude you got to be a loser to like
this guy what is there to like nothing
what am i missing about this guy oh he's
mysterious ugh
live shows are crazy like this
with this mystery the live shows are
crazy you should show them to you look
at these mysterious [ __ ] as
they get older and be like you are a
goofy yeah mystery song
you're a [ __ ] dork history you're a
[ __ ] dork what's that motherfucker's
name uh pirates of the caribbean johnny
depp dips
cut it out
come on cut it out with that [ __ ]
cut it the [ __ ] out whatever it says
your hands say what what's wrong with
that fire when you're young yo young and
mysterious fire dog yeah but grow up old
and mysterious you've got to grow up
nah don't be old and mysterious and
still want people if you were older
mysterious you got to do it brando style
you got to like go to your own island
you got to really check out you can't be
old and mysterious and still want the
limelight
yeah the thing about mystery is it can't
want
it can't want shine too much light no it
does too much light reveals the mystery
yeah but you can't be mysterious with a
401k
i mean like yeah you're upset about your
[ __ ] tesla stock yeah you can't have
investments in you guys
advisor
or on an island like brando is deadass
mysterious but he was able to remove
himself enough from us so we kept on
yeah we can't see that he had back pain
every [ __ ] morning like he's just
tired all the time just like oh my god
my ankle hurts for no reason he got a
root canal yeah you deal with old man
[ __ ] yeah right
you know marilyn manson is dealing with
old man's [ __ ] i see him aging yes
embarrassing but like physical old man
[ __ ] because when you're old
everything's already mysterious yeah i
mean like how long you're gonna live
yeah i gotta get a [ __ ] finger in my
ass once a week like i gotta get
prostate exams like your whole life's a
mystery you don't need an added mystery
to you like kinky [ __ ] becomes
scientific like he had to beg rose
mcgaren to finger his ass yeah and now
he's in the proctologist once a month
getting his [ __ ] dug out to make sure he
doesn't have colin kansas
yeah
oh it's so corny yeah being mysterious
is a grown adult like so corny yeah and
you still need it he still puts the
makeup on his old ass head yeah
oh that's it
probably it's a wig at this point yo son
that's wake up in the middle of the
night put on his hair
[ __ ] come over for a booty call
there's a shelf life to a character yeah
and a shelf life of you yourself
you could people there could be like you
know people could wane in interest and
there could be increases in that
interest as well but
and they evolve with you
yes but there's no shelf life but if
you're a character you outgrow the
character as a fan people outgrow it
that's what i'm saying as a fan you
outgrow the character yeah yeah i'm
tired of when you were 13 and you loved
marilyn manson when we i think i was
like in middle school when he came
around you might have been no i did not
yeah you just say you did you just said
you liked me
yeah loser ass
nerd
yeah but the problem is when you get
older i used to dress in all black i
used to wear nail polish like mark
i love nail polish let me wear that [ __ ]
i wore a nail polish yeah it's dope when
you're young
as well no i had yeah i i would uh i
paint teardrops right here
wait why because [ __ ] would be asking
me about them and then they get [ __ ]
with their fat ass
that's how you catch a hog anything to
get the girl to to start the convo with
him
i didn't like talking to these girls
they got to talk to me but i had to do
things to give them an excuse to talk to
them they were mysterious
talking to the girl you were marilyn
manson he wasn't mysterious and then i
grew out of it
no for real i think you should do all
that [ __ ] and the girl's like oh who'd
you murder and you're like this [ __ ]
and all that
ally
no but for real as i always thought
as a younger as a youngin so i could go
up to these girls and like introduce
myself and do all that kind of [ __ ] or i
could just dress like abraham lincoln
with gang taps yeah that would be good
a little wayne's so much easier and even
if you're just having like that [ __ ]
uh
look i would have that weird hat what
was that [ __ ] hat the korean old
ladies who wear it the one with the
sequins
like it's not like a floridian
i know which one you're talking about so
the little bill in the front little bill
right on the bill but the whole thing
was like sequence but it didn't matter
it was just like i i don't know i was
kind of like analyzing these like social
interactions and i was like okay the
beginning part is the toughest because
people don't know what to say
and if there's something to comment on
then let's give them something to talk
about hey i see you hundred percent
hundred percent he read that book yeah
the game yeah yeah and he just really
applied it to his life the original time
i actually thought that that book was
really corny at first i i've read it i
was like this is so [ __ ] cool like
wow there these guys like figured out
how to talk to girls and then i realized
wait a minute like they're just saying
the same line every time little did i
know i would do that for a living
entertaining people with the same words
and uh but i thought it was corny
because i was like wait but i'm not
getting this [ __ ] off my merit yeah
like some other [ __ ] has hacked
this [ __ ] and they're telling me so i
tried to understand like what was going
on in these interactions uh you want to
find your own little social hacking yeah
yeah so and i was just like you're
writing bits i was writing bits but it
was like
what is the easier way if a girl even if
a girl does like you she might also be
nervous in that moment so it's like
finding things where she could also feel
comfortable that's why i was doing magic
tricks bro yeah that works too and it's
like
you didn't [ __ ] you just did the magic
and then went home yeah i'm passionate
about illusions like duh of course
passionate about
the illusion that you will [ __ ] her yeah
bro you'd be kicking crazy games yeah
she was like wait wait are you leaving
yeah i'd be like come back to my room
and i'd disappear and i'd be like oh
where'd i go the greatest of tricks
yeah the uh but yeah but like you don't
know you do that thing and it kind of
loosens everything up and then you're
already talking you're talking about
something else and then it's done
the most inauthentic part of stand-up
and one of the great things about having
an audience of people that come see you
is the introduction
i have to like trick people into
thinking this is a normal thing to do
which is stand up in front of people and
then talk
i hated it in the same way that i hated
just like walking up to a group of girls
like hi i'd like your [ __ ] because
that's what i'm doing
hi i like your [ __ ]
that's the honest thing hi i'd like to
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you first then maybe
you and then you if you're willing but
ideally here that is the authentic way
to walk up to a group of women yeah if
you were going to be honest yeah so i
have to lie to you so instead of lying
why don't i put you in the position
where you have to lie
right yeah i like your hat no you don't
you don't like my hat hey we're talking
and you came up to me and now we're
having fun but you want the dirt
yes but i don't know i just thought that
was or like even in like the bar of the
club like positioning ourselves in a
place where like the girls would walk by
us mm-hmm
like in the girls stall yeah like that's
actually smart yeah you know but like
trying to hand them napkins and [ __ ]
while they're washing their hands i just
start working there
i don't know you're just sitting in that
part of the place and then the girls are
walking by because they want to get to
the bar they want to go to the dance
floor and it's like there's something
that happens like even if you hit on a
girl as she's walking by you
the fact that she's approaching you yeah
how dare you walk by me and not say
what's up or like
like she thinks she's talking to you
like you came here yeah there's
something like um her defenses are down
like if somebody approaches you the
defense going up like the [ __ ] is this
guy how do we get him out of here you
walk by me you walked into myspace
yeah i don't know do they have the
bathroom attendance in girls bathrooms
they have to right they must i've never
thought about that i've never i've never
felt like a job never bothered asking
terrible what listen to the guy's [ __ ]
all day and give him mints no girls is
worse dog why
it's just girl [ __ ] all day yo
yeah it's just the beepy time you never
[ __ ] at a club i mean me i'm different
yeah he's built different right i
guarantee you girls be sitting in that
club yeah it's just people times rips
letting
there's a comic named josh johnson and
he has a funny bit about the uh you know
that like hand dryer in the bathroom
and he goes uh
where's that air come from
that's funny yeah
is that [ __ ] air that you're cleaning
your [ __ ] hands with and it might be
right i've heard they're like very
unsanitary
those hand dryers yeah if it's just
recycling the air that's in there yeah i
don't want that put on my hands yeah
yeah like directly all over my hands i
thought that was a funny aztec yeah
because you never even think about it
right you look at those machines all the
goddamn time and everything about once
what up people you just watch a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
you